♪ ♪
>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR A
FINAL EXAM WHEN WE LEARN WHO HAD
FOX HAS BEEN PAYING ATTENTION TO
IT'S OUR JOB TO DO THAT.
THIS IS OUR DEFENDING CHAMPION,
BRETT LARSON AND THE CHALLENGER,
ONE OF THE WORLD'S GREAT EXPERTS
OF VIDEO GAMES.
THANK YOU FOR KEEPING ABREAST OF
THAT INDUSTRY.
>> I TRIED.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW THE RULES,
I BEG YOUR PARDON, BUT FOR THE
VIEWERS WHO MAY NOT, I'M GOING
TO ASK THE QUESTION, THE FIRST
ONE WHO BUZZES GETS TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL I FINISH
ASKING IT.
EACH ANSWER IS WHAT THE POINT,
IF YOU GET IT WRONG, YOU LOSE A
POINT.
BEST-OF-FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> AS READY AS I'LL EVER BE.
THIS BILL IN QUESTION ONE,
MARK ZUCKERBERG GOT GRILLED ON
CAPITOL HILL AND WAS ASKED
REPEATEDLY ABOUT THE CENSORSHIP
OF FACEBOOK OF TWO CONSERVATIVE
SISTERS, THESE SISTERS ARE
FAMOUS ON MINE FOR SUPPORTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHO ARE THEY?
>> DIAMOND AND SILK.
>> Tucker: THIEVES OR PEOPLE
I'M ASKING ABOUT.
LET'S SEE IF YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> DIAMOND AND SILK HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU.
>> LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING
RIGHT NOW, DIAMOND AND SILK IS
NOT TERRORISM.
>> WHY IS FACEBOOK A SENSOR AND
CONSERVATIVE BLOCKERS SUCH AS
DIAMOND AND SOCCER?
>> THIS IS DANGEROUS.
>> I BELIEVE THAT IS DIAMOND AND
SILK.
>> Tucker: EVERYBODY KNOWS
DIAMOND AND SILK INCLUDING JEFF.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> IT YOU'RE LIKE A FACTION OF
THE SECOND --
>> Tucker: WHICH UFC FIGHTER
IS OUT ON BAIL TONIGHT AFTER
GRABBING A HAND TRUCK AND
THROWING IT THROUGH THE WINDOW
OF A BUS IN BROOKLYN, NEW YORK?
>> CONNOR McGREGOR.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE UP ON THIS.
IS IT CONNOR McGREGOR?
I DON'T KNOW.
>> UFC CHAMPION CONNOR
McGREGOR TURNS HIMSELF INTO
AUTHORITIES LAST NIGHT FOLLOWING
HIS RAMPAGE BACKSTAGE AT THE
BARCLAYS CENTER.
[BLEEP] [BLEEP] >> I HAVE TO
GIVE MAD PROPS.
>> Tucker: I SCOFF AT THE IDEA
OF TOXIC MASCULINITY, BUT IF
THAT EXISTS, THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
WHAT THE MONGOLS ACROSS THE
RUSSIAN STEPS, YOU ARE SWEEPING.
QUESTION THREE.
WHICH MEMBER OF THE ROYAL FAMILY
HAS THE WORLD IN HYSTERICS THIS
WEEK WHEN HE OR SHE JOKINGLY
COMPARED A NOISY HELICOPTER TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OBAMA?
KATIE E.
THE QUEEN  .
>> Tucker: FROM WHAT COUNTRY?
>> BRITAIN.
>> THAT SOUNDS LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Tucker: WE ARE NOT
IMPRESSED.
IS THE QUEEN ADEQUATE?
THEY ARE SAYING IT IS.
KATIE, ALL RIGHT.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES IS
FIGHTING GLOBAL WARMING BY
TAKING AN UNUSUAL APPROACH.
THIS APPROACH INVOLVES PAINT.
WHAT IS THE CITY DOING?
IT INVOLVES PAINT.
IT'S A HUFFING PAINT UNTIL THE
PROBLEM GOES AWAY.
>> THEY'RE GOING TO HUG A TREE
EVERY TIME THEY PAINT A WALL?
>> IS IT SOMETHING --
>> Tucker: KNOWN.
KATIE?
>> IT DOESN'T HAVE SOMETHING TO
DO WITH THE SUN AND THE HEAT?
>> Tucker: CAN YOU BE MORE
SPECIFIC?
>> SOMETHING FROM REFLECTING THE
SUN OFF THE HEAT?
I HAVE NO IDEA.
SPEAK OF THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
IS USING TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE BY
PAINTING WHITE.
IT'S COSTING THE CITY NEARLY
$40,000 PER MILE.
>> Tucker: YOU JUST MADE THAT
UP ON THE FLY.
YOU SHOULD BE A GLOBAL WARMING
ENGINEER.
I'M IMPRESSED THAT YOU GOT IT.
MAYBE SHE'LL MAKE UP THIS ONE
TOO.
FINAL QUESTION, ILLINOIS
SENATOR JUST BECAME THE FIRST
SITTING U.S. SENATOR TO DO THIS
WHILE IN OFFICE.
>> YOU DIDN'T WAIT FOR HIM TO
FINISH.
>> SHE'S PREGNANT AND SHE'S
GOING TO HAVE A BABY.
FIRST FEMALE SENATOR TO HAVE A
BABY.
>> Tucker: KATIE GETS TO
ANSWER FIRST.
SPEAK OUT FIRST SENATOR TO HAVE
A BABY?
>> Tucker: I'M REFLECTING THE
JUDGMENT OF THE JUDGES.
I AM MERELY A NEUTRAL ARBITER
HERE, A PUPPET CONTROLLED.
YOUR GUESS IS THE FIRST SENATOR
TO GIVE BIRTH MIRRORING BRETT
WHO BUZZED IN EARLY.
LET'S SEE IF YOU AND HIM WERE
RIGHT.
>> SENATOR TAMMY DUCKWORTH OF
ILLINOIS HAS GIVEN BIRTH TO A
BABY GIRL MAKING HER THE FIRST
SENATOR TO GIVE BIRTH WHILE IN
OFFICE.
OUR CONGRATULATIONS TO HER AND
LITTLE BABY MILEY.
>> AND MY CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU.
GOOD ANSWER.
>> Tucker: BITTERSWEET.
WE HAVE A TECHNICALITY, WE ARE
GOING TO THROW IN ONE BONUS
QUESTION.
THE BONUS QUESTION ALWAYS
REMAINS THE SAME AND THE JUDGES
TOLD ME TO MAKE IT UP ON THE FLY
TOLD ME TO MAKE IT UP ON THE FL
FLY.
I I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOIN
I I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOIG
WITH THE ANSWER.
WHAT IS THE CAPITAL OF
BURKINA FASO?
THE FORMER -- IT HAS A CAPITAL
CALLED WHAT?
COME ON!
THAT WAS IT.
>> CAN I CHIME IN FOR PANDAS?
>> Tucker: NO, YOU MAY NOT.
YOU ALL WERE GREAT.
I'M SORRY EIGHT ENDS THIS WAY.
YOU DID A REMARKABLE JOB.
YOU WIN THE COVETED MUG WHICH
SHOWS ERIC WEDDLE AND HIS
SEGMENT ON OUR SHOW.